I wouldn't dare try I don't even want
the possibility of becoming addicted to
something that is going to make me
physically dependent upon it my name is
Kayla and I'm a recovery advocate hi my
name is Chris and I'm a cannabis
abdicating hi my name is Devin and I'm
fascinated with mental health
my name is Juan comedic one-sided such
what there's an area that the gringos JC
and I am Pro these things that are grow
out of the ground and make us shift our
perspective
my name is key I am honestly middle
ground my name is Kiki Dexter and I'm
here pro-marijuana
[Music]
so my sister went to rehab for extensive
drugs usage it affected her life very
heavily and was in rehab cost my parents
a lot of time and energy money and just
emotional draining for the whole family
my dad is a very adamantly trying
recovering heroin addict I think he
first got addicted when he was like 20
it was the influx of drugs into the
cities in the 80s
it still affects his life I had a
physical dependence on prescription
anti-anxiety medication
klonopin specifically for like seven
years I went to treatment like three
years ago and eventually found my way
back I would consider myself sober I've
been sober for like two and a half years
alcohol played a big role in my life
marijuana played a big role in my life I
didn't notice
going into my 20s that the pattern that
I do have a propensity to want to get
[ __ ] up now I like I don't smoke I
don't drink or at least that's my
intention but there comes a time when
it's like cool I think I could go for a
nice LSD trip and woods that'd be nice
people often become emotionally
dependent on recreational drugs
yeah I think they do um for example I
had a great childhood but I was sexually
abused nobody knew what was going on how
do you by the time I was 14 I was using
whatever I could get my hands on to deal
with the emotional turmoil that I was
dealing with inside and when we're so
young we have traumatic events or we
have these situations and these
circumstances that stick with us and we
don't know how to process them and so we
reach out to whatever's closest to is
food addiction drug addiction I think
it's it's good to establish a
distinction between recreational use and
habitual use because that's something I
heard you guys talking about and I don't
feel that people really become
emotionally dependent when they're
recreationally using it when they're
habitually using it when they're using
it to solve problems then it does become
an issue because you're not dealing with
balance at that point I mean you're
tipping one way on the scale you're
clearly going to affect other areas and
get sick
I don't know what I think actually I
agree sup guys this is the heart one for
me I just had a hone in on that word
moderation like if I'm smoking once or
twice a week that's fine but if I'm
smoking every day of my life every
second I get up and I can't function
then a you know of course that's when
there's a red line I wouldn't say like
using things like heroin or cocaine like
use not a moderation I think that's just
harmful but if we're talking about the
subject of marijuana and that use yeah
well here's why I disagree I think there
are levels to this I don't think all
drugs are safe even in moderation like
you take a wrong Molly or whatever the
percocet pill is like you know like
people have died from that and that was
technically in moderation one pill one
day life gone you know like same thing
with heroin like that's something that
could drastically change your life in a
day the moderation part of it is tough
because with pharmaceuticals mainly to
me you mix two those things you're gone
and that's terrifying yeah and there are
so many circumstances where it only
takes one time to become physically
dependent even in in my case um I take
prescription medication for sleeping I
hate that I'm on it and I hate that I
have to use it to function if you don't
have to absolutely do it why do it so
let me ask you this so what's the
distinction for you between that and
like ayahuasca peyote DMT different it's
not necessary I think there's this a
distinction that I know I'm gonna invite
you to look at it's like there is a
difference between cocaine oh I was
right but what I'm saying is neither
aren't necessary my question to you is
are you saying to all the young people
like you will not be able to open your
mind fully unless you go and do this no
what I'm saying is that I hold everybody
high and I hold everybody with the
ability to think for themselves but also
going out and having an intentional
purposeful responsible encounter
with mushrooms or LSD supported me in
getting over my addiction to marijuana
and alcohol but the point being is the
safety issue and what you might have
gone in that moment when you took the
drugs and it opened your mind and you
were able to realize a lot of stuff I
think people should do on their own
without the drugs drugs reduce people's
potential
I think even with psychedelic drugs you
know to the point earlier even if they
are opening your mind of that's really
not your potential
that's not your potential your potential
is the organic potential and a lot of
your organic self is wonderful and it is
marvelous and if you take a little time
to work and develop that muscle like a
talent then you will be able to reach
your fullest potential when I got sober
I went back to school which I never
thought I would do I work two jobs I
started a small business like I think of
all of the people who are usually
hypersensitive and end up getting into
drugs because they can't deal with our
emotions and all those people could be
potentially adding to society and
they're not because they're in their own
world so I really don't feel that they
harm people's potential and I think that
helped people gain their potential in a
lot of different ways and I mean with
cannabis alone I mean we have an
endocannabinoid system within our body I
mean it's one of our main receptors it
within our brain that it's like a lock
and key for cannabis it's we're made of
the same materials our brain synthesizes
those materials within it so I I really
do feel that our potential isn't high
hindered by drugs I mean some totally I
can see some 100% but overall natural
ones not at all
some of the most powerful people in the
world right now in Silicon Valley and
creating some of the most powerful
startups are all micro dosing totally
two years ago I did had my first
mushroom experience so I went into the
woods I went in nature I set the
intention I'm gonna have this experience
that I've never had before it was a
remarkable experience and I felt a
deeper truth within my connection to the
earth something I hadn't had in a long
time and it was kind of reconnection
with my spirituality I relate to you
because I also come from a very
spiritual background I think wherever
that framework is for you like if it's
drugs then that's for you I think that's
a dangerous path I also think that for
me that that thing is God you know like
me having faith in God in a relationship
with God that is that is the opening to
my spirituality like I don't need to
take drugs to get there have you done
stuck it on
so it's it's like someone that hasn't
done had sex talking about why no it's
not that's not what it's like at all
like it because but the thing is I don't
need to know that's my point - my point
is you don't need to know you have you
do do you have a relationship with
Christ you know have you spoken in
tongues that doesn't mean anything
that's a cross it's not a relationship
it's not a relationship the two are very
different that's my point so you don't
have to ask me what I did not do what I
said was and I repeat it my experience
and my relationship with Christ for me
that supersedes my desire to even go
into that path because I find myself
very happy very successful very I'm
thriving within my being and I don't
need the substitution there is a lot of
false information about recreational
drugs
it's like based on the culture the
perception and I'm strictly talking
about marijuana but you know at one
point in history it was also used for
medicine it was it was used for religion
it was used for you know for hip was
used for a variety of things like so and
there's people that don't know that it's
a part of our history so when I think
about how ill informed people are that's
one of the main things but the truth is
like do I really want all of the
information I'll be honest no I don't I
don't I don't really need it you know I
agree with the statement that's why I
walked over because I will agree that
like there are there's a lot that I
don't know about recreational drugs and
I think that there's a lot that most
people don't know yeah I mean I walked
over for the same thing I try and keep
an open mind at all times and realized
that a wise man knows that he knows
nothing so especially with cannabis in
that I'm aware and have researched you
know cannabis oils and taken CBD and
myself and I am interested in as someone
who takes pharmaceutical medication as
cannabis as an alternative but my
perspective and once again versus
recreational versus I would consider
that for me medical use there's a great
deal of misinformation I mean just like
the pharmaceutical guy I mean we have
all these things that are getting pumped
into our homes all the time with all of
these side effects and side effects the
side effects more than half the
commercial it's all side effects yet
it's selling it's okay to take that it's
cool to take that yeah you can probably
kill you but it's okay to take that but
you can't takes each other yeah
take this one and take this one but
don't take this thing over here that can
actually help you exactly and I think
that's because there are people that
benefit from are exactly like that's not
being literal but I have to realize like
why why we're here for this video is
pushing information and for recreational
drug purposes and like the
misinformation but I think that it takes
a lot more education and usually a
really bad circumstance for you to want
to change around your life and be like
[ __ ] what am i doing like there has to
be more than this but most people never
get uncomfortable enough to need to make
that realization and so I'm I'm just not
going to push it because I just think
that it's going to end up way more
negative unfortunately
[Music]
people hey guys it's Kendra from Jubilee
media thank you so much for watching
this episode of middle ground we really
try to inspire radical empathy through
our episodes so make sure you let us
know what you thought in the comments
below subscribe follow us on Instagram
and we'll see you next time